c'est un mec qui rentre dans une
animalerie et il dit bonjour monsieur je
vais me est-ce que j'aimerais avoir un
chien de garde un Molos vraiment un
chien qui fait peur il dit il n'y a pas
de souci monsieur regardez j'ai ce petit
caniche à vous proposer vous foutez de
ma gueule ou quoi je viens de vous dire
je veux un chien de garde il dit mais
vous rendez pas compte c'est pas un
caniche comme les autres ça c'est un
caniche qui fait du karaté d'ailleurs
c'est son prénom et s'appelle karaté et
pour l'activer vous dites deux fois de
karaté et il fera qu'à tout ce qui bouge
tiens voyez pour voir karaté karaté
porte
[Rires]
tu vois c'est impressionnant je peux
essayer karaté karaté table fracasse la
table monsieur c'est parfait j'achète ce
petit chien il rentre chez lui chez ses
potes le soir et ses potes il lui dit
alors tu l'as acheté ce chien il dit
voilà le petit caniche ça les gars il
dit c'est quoi ce chien vous êtes malade
ou quoi ça c'est un chien qui fait du
karaté et un pote il dit ouais karaté
karaté mes couilles
[Applaudissements]